in machine learning one of the most
fundamental tasks is when you have a
bunch of objects that you want to
classify into two categories or more is
this picture of a dog or cat
is this stock going up or down svms or
support vector machines are some of the
simplest and arguably the most elegant
methods for classification each object
you want to classify is represented as a
point in an n-dimensional space and the
coordinates of this point are usually
called features
svms perform the classification test by
drawing a hyperplane that is a line in
2d or a plane in 3d in such a way that
all points of one category are on one
side of the hyperplane and all points of
the other category are on the other side
and while there could be multiple such
hyperplanes svm tries to find the one
that best separates the two categories
in the sense that it maximizes the
distance to points in either category
this distance is called the margin and
the points that fall exactly on the
margin are called the supporting vectors
to find this hyperplane in the first
place svm requires a training set or a
set of points that are already labeled
with the correct category this is why
svm is said to be a supervised learning
algorithm in the background svm solves a
convex optimization problem that
maximizes this margin and where the
constraints say that points of each
category should be on the correct side
of the hyperplane in practice you don't
have to worry about the implementation
details of this optimization problem
using svm can be as simple as loading a
python library preparing your training
data feeding it to the fit function and
calling predict to assign the correct
category to a new object
the biggest pros of svms is that they
are easy to understand implement use and
interpret
furthermore they are effective when the
size of the training data is small the
simplicity of svms can also be a problem
in many applications the points cannot
be separated by hyperplane a common
workaround in this case is 2a augmented
data with some nonlinear features that
are computed from the existing ones
b find the separating hyperplane in this
higher dimensional space and c project
back to the original space
a clever technique known as the kernel
track allows us to perform all of these
steps in a very efficient manner and now
that you know about svms you can use
them for face detection spam fill train
and text recognition
this was svm in about 2 minutes like and
subscribe if you liked the video and see
you next time